realllly die what's the purpose of life
brother and he gonna show you all the
features mean I'm gonna die Salam
alaikum peace be unto you thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Deen
show you have testified you declared
what's in your very nature that there is
only one God that I will not worship a
man a monkey an elephant an ant a mouse
the Sun the moon
I'm not going to worship any of these
things I'm not going to worship a man or
woman I'm gonna I'm gonna worship the
creator of man and woman and I'm gonna
obey the messenger that was sent if I
was living during the time of Jesus I
would have followed his teachings he was
the way the true from the light if I was
living during the time of Moses I would
have followed his teachings but the last
and final message sent to mankind is the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him you
have testified to this you testify to it
you started to get into establishing the
prayers five times a day and you're
checking into the fasting ramadan is
coming up and all the other pillars of
islam is very simple as rational now
there's some confusion you're asking
questions there's some things you're
studying but you're going to some of the
messages you're hanging around with some
people who got the name tagless love but
you've seen that hold on I'm reading
something I'm investigating Quran says
this the way of the Prophet says that
where they getting this stuff homes back
home culture or is this Islam all this
and more next on Adi show Allah there's
only one
muhammad is his messenger Allah Allah
[Music]
there's only one where Jesus was his
messenger why did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice
Salaam alaikum peace be with you
waalaikum Salaam peace be with you to
thank you for being with us Karadzic oh
it's a pleasure thanks for having me
thank you and we're gonna get straight
into topic because the time pretty soon
we'll be going to commercial break
another conversion is done is finished
that's right so we're going to get
straight down to business
we want to follow the way the way that
has been sent down by the creator of the
heavens and her soul to those sincere
and humble people I just want you to be
able to show how many other of the
different people who had a messenger and
then they started to follow back home
cultures and things got all mixed up and
the people want to straight we see it
happening today you have the kind of
obey the Word of God and you have the
Sunnah of the way the authentic
teachings are last and final messenger
but man now seem to become like of a
faith you got this person doing this
from his back home culture and there's
some good food and good other things in
culture and there's no problem there so
how do we differentiate what is the
correct way and back home culture thing
is that just been created by man can you
just briefly touch upon the history of
how other generations when they went
away for the teaching of their prophets
things got out of control and how we
don't want that to happen to us today
well if you look in the history of how
people okay from from the point of view
of the teaching of the Quran the
original religion of human beings was
the worship of the one good not the
story that we have been given through
evolution that human beings you know as
they evolved they were worshipping all
these different things that they were
afraid of and then you know as they
evolved more they you know started
worshipping fewer and fewer gods and
then they had a sky god and a
they have this you know one god and then
eventually you know according to this
logic when we evolved enough we realized
there is no God you know this is their
this is their idea but no we believe of
course that the first human being was
Adam that God created Adam and from Adam
he created even from Adam and Eve came
many men and women yes and the original
religion of Adam and the children of
Adam the descendants of Adam was one of
the ISM the worship of the One God there
was actually amongst the people of Noah
the Prophet Noah his people were the
first people to worship idols and they
did that by it wasn't really a trick of
the devil
Shaitaan you know they had amongst them
some pious people those pious people
died they became really really upset and
then they were exact you know they were
just too much upset and this is where
Shaitaan saw his opportunity so he came
to them and then he encouraged them to
do something that Adam had never taught
that had never been part of the religion
he said why don't you make statues and
why do you make pictures of these pious
people and hang them in your homes and
put them in your places of gathering so
when you see them you will remember God
more so it was a new thing was an
innovation in religion it was not
something the prophets had ever taught
and it was a suggestion from the devil
but what is really interesting is that
the devil suggested something that seems
to be good what's wrong with remembering
God more
you see I see this pious person I
remember how good they were I remember
how holy there they were I get
encouraged you know to be a more pious
person from the outside it seems good
but of course Shaitaan has a big plan so
now what happens that is it the devil
there's a Satanic Verses
will know Shaitaan himself does he have
also hit descendents though he does but
you know he's Shaitaan is a living in
visual beam not a human being but a
Jinni which is like a spirit okay so
anyway he but he's waiting and what
happens after generations past the
people forgot why their ancestors had
made these statues as that's what
happens after time people forgot and
then Shaitaan came to them the devil
came to them and he said you know why
your ancestors made these statues so
that in your time of distress and need
you should go and ask these people
because they're pious people God is not
gonna listen to you you're so full of
sin so you ask these pious people and
they will take your prayers to God they
will be intercessors between you and God
and this is how people started to
worship idols and this is idolatry this
is why in Islam worshipping Saints
praying to prophets you know calling
upon them thinking that they will take
your prayers to God as if you have an
intermediate real world this is all
considered to be idolatry but the guy
says look I mean he said this was a
righteous man I myself am NOT that
righteous all I'm doing is asking him
because look you can make dua for me
okay the first thing is they're dead and
dead people can't he so cooling upon a
dead person is like cooling up on a
brick and brick the dead can't he the
Quran says in naka advertise me or not
you can't make the dead to hear all
right if I always giving this example
say meaning you can't just as you can't
make dead people here you can't make a
person who doesn't want to know the
truth you can't make them follow it but
the point is that Allah is showing the
dead can't hear you and an obstinate
person who doesn't want to listen you
can't made them listen so the dead can
hear calling upon a dead person right
and I mean dead in the physical sense
okay they may be spiritually alive but
they are dead they are not in this world
anymore you can't marry them you can't
do business with them you can't trade
with them right you know so that you
can't have a conversation
so it's cut off oh yeah and that's what
it means but is that gayness that's why
we don't believe in ghosts there's no
like souls of dead people wandering
around no the dead are in another
dimension yes their souls exist but they
can't hear us
okay so cooling upon a dead person it
doesn't matter how priced they are even
the Prophet Muhammad Jesus Moses doesn't
matter who it is if they you know they
are in that other the buzick there's a
barrier that's a barrier the dead can't
hear the living so calling upon them is
like calling upon a brick because they
can't hear you so the issue is is
nothing to do it how pious they are
it's just that calling upon dead people
if the pious person was sitting right
here and I say Oh aiding you such a good
holy man can you ask but that's fine
there's no problem you can ask a person
who's living and right here if you think
they're righteous but if he's in
Connecticut or in when you command well
you can form them on the phone but if
you can you sit here like this no you
know put a big picture in front of you
and start to you know talk to him
organization of course that's the same
thing that's calling upon something that
can't hear and can't help you right and
the only one that we should call upon
like that is Allah is God the Creator
the only one that we should call upon
like that is done because the only one
who can hear you wherever you are even
if you are an ant inside a rock on the
deepest part of the ocean God can hear
the call of that man so this is not
Islam this is some kind of culture
paganism that's crept yeah absolutely so
this is our area that this is a really
good example of how people followed the
way of their ancestors and following
aware of their ancestors led them to
commit the worst crime a human being can
ever make and that is to make a partner
or
or an associate with God to worship
something when you should only worship
God only worship God we'll be right back
with more in the detail when outside
everything looks good you see the
hundred thousand dollar car you see a
lot of diamonds you see a lot of females
and they think that this is you know
this is the life this is this is like no
paradise right here our job to go into
someone's heart to change their
heartbeat your job is to topi what the
truth is and the alley of it is while
we're sitting here I'm sitting here
constantly paying for the disease to
kill with free
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
we are back here on the Dean show you
gave a beautiful example this is in the
Koran the verbatim would have got this
example the the story of Noah is in the
Koran but this how the people actually
came to worship idols is not in the
Koran it was mentioned by Abdullah even
Abbas who was the cousin of the Prophet
and he was very well known for his
explaining the Quran so obviously he
heard this from the Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu this is a piece of listen to
the point this is a beautiful example
how when you deviate a little bit from
the game plan the blueprint you go
astray yeah and then you see the thing
with the people then that people think
this is religion yeah they think that
this is the religion and the same thing
was the case in the time of the Prophet
Mohammed you know and in fact if you
read the Quran you will find all the
prophets Jesus face the same thing you
know this there's a famous well that's I
know how famous it is these days but
there's you know there's a story in the
Gospels yeah tell us well just one of
the stories in the Gospels that is
mentioned is about you know how those
people those those Pharisees and those
rabbis they had taken they had made
things up basically and they gave those
things the weight that should only be
given to the laws of God so they they
the the man-made ideas that they had the
man-made concepts that they had they
actually really gave them that authority
as if those things were from God right
so you find that this is something the
all the prophets are experiencing
they're coming to tell people this is
not the religion this is not what God
told you to do God never commanded you
to do this but those people have
supplanted the true religion that was
bought with the messengers for their own
man-made cultures and customs now maybe
that sometimes means you see when it
comes to when it comes to the religion
of Islam Islam has a built-in
flexibility that allows it to really
we practice just about anywhere and so
sometimes we do take into account the
culture of people let me give you an
example rate in some societies right
just a simple thing what if I undid my
buttons right will down the way down to
my chest and I'm doing my buttons you
show my chest right and some societies
and some cultures they would look down
on that and say well that's how bad
people you know gangsters they dressed
like that you know with their shirts
open right ok whatever right so the
point is being here is that a Muslim
should not look like a gangster or a bad
person right you should try and look
respectable but sometimes what is
respectable is different from society to
society even though the Prophet Muhammad
himself used to keep it isn't buttons
open yeah right but then no one
considered that to be something just
respectable in that society so you see
some of those things may change from
culture to culture certain situation
into situation and these are not things
that Islam has ordered disordered that
right rather Islam has ordered us to be
good it's all of us to be of the best
character of the best type of behavior
we can have many examples Muslims are
famous everywhere for being late you
want to organize a dinner you want to
organize a talk you tell everyone we'll
start at 7 o'clock long turns up to 8
o'clock and they don't think you're
going to start to 8:30 whereas in the
West if you tell people come at 8 you
expecting people there to be 8 maybe
five past 8:00 maybe 15 past at the
latest you don't expect people to turn
up an hour and a half late it's
considered really bad manners so these
things change from culture to culture
now the problem is a lot of Muslims they
have adopted habits and customs and
practices that are from their culture
which may be perfectly acceptable where
they come from well that doesn't mean
the less acceptable way to behave in the
West some of those practices may be
necessary for whatever reasons I don't
know maybe there's scarcity of food
scarcity of whatever I don't know it did
the difference
Constance's they may even have practices
that are necessary and beneficial in the
land they came from but they have no
importance and relevance in you know in
the Western context now the problem is
Muslims come from different countries to
live in the West and they bring their
culture with them and they think that
this package they have is Islam because
Islam is such a deep part of their
culture it's so deep in their culture
they think that what they do is Islam
but it's not always the case now give
you an example the best example I think
is of arranged marriages like forced
marriages forced marriages and arranged
marriages now for now even in some
cultures they have forced marriages
where literally a woman even a man it's
not just a woman the man and the woman
are literally just married that
sometimes they don't even know that
they're married they just that's it
that's your husband that's your wife
they have no choice they have no say now
actually from the point of view of
Islamic law this is not even considered
to be valid it's not valid because part
of a marriage being considered to be
valid in Islamic law is that the two
people who are getting married agree to
it so this is again culture has nothing
to do with this it has nothing to do
with is it safe to say that Islam didn't
come to eradicate all different customs
of cultures the things that are bad
exactly it kept the good kept the gross
the good things if there's a good thing
in a culture like being polite or like
being on time or like being clean as
I'll say give that up okay but walking
in the street with a thong that's and
that's your culture everybody's doing it
working and no because obviously you
know that song I understand what of the
audience so if that's called this is
just an extreme extreme example or you
walk around in baby suits no in this
town of course the Islam has some limits
yeah right so what a person can do and
can't do has to fit the limits of the
divine legislation yeah God has given us
a type of you know a type of limit that
we should follow in terms of women's
dress and men's dress right interaction
between the sickness X's right there are
some limits
these limits have been laid down by
Allah and you should follow those limits
but within those limits right you have
flexibility so address but as long as
it's modest exactly talking say for
example a woman's dress a woman's dress
she should she should cover everything
except her face and her hands
and people should recognize her as a
Muslim but as long as you fulfill those
conditions and the clothes are loose it
doesn't mean you have to wear the burqa
like in Saudi Arabia or in Afghanistan
even if you look at the dress of the
women in Afghanistan it's different the
veil is different in Afghanistan than it
is from Saudi Arabia so now the culture
if it's a different little style
patterns and now that's the culture it
depends you look in Nigeria for example
okay and they were very colorful very
bright clothes because really probably
in different cultures you will find that
that is not considered to be you know
like enticing words maybe in Saudi
Arabia it would be so these things are
going to be you know are going to change
from time to time I place the place but
the basic rule is when a woman is out in
Islam
she should only show her face in her
hands if she wants to cover her face
that's good she can do that if she wants
now if you gave example force marriages
arranged marriages is different I want
to introduce you your son to my daughter
and see if they like each other under
supervision arranged marriages are
normal again it's part of the culture in
Muslim countries the follow the religion
the sex is tend to be quite segregated
you know they don't really mix they'll
go mix up school they don't mix at
university then on the limited mixing in
the workplace even in the marketplaces
you know so the segregation is the tech
from promiscuity
I'll give this reason spur we don't go
into that but the point is is that there
are good reasons for it yeah but that is
the sort of normal pattern you know so
how does the boy meet a girl the only
way ultimately you meet and get married
is through family and through friends
because practically let's the only way
to do it
yeah does that mean if a Muslim girl in
Canada for example or in the States
yeah goes to university and a Muslim boy
and they meet each other and you know
they talk and they get to like each
other you know is that necessarily you
know does that mean that this marriage
is not allowed because it wasn't
arranged No
people can beat each other they can like
each other but obviously they need to
follow the limits of Islam which means
the girl of the the man should go and
seek permission to marry this girl from
her father
normally her father but whoever her
guardian is and she should get his
permission and the marriage should be
done according to the rules in Islam
okay so they should agree there should
be witnesses the father should witness
okay so as long as those things are
there and as long as they're meeting and
talking with each other
is not leading them to you know things
that are forbidden in Islam then okay
that's a different culture we live in a
different culture in the West so we
explained that and then force marriage
is forcing a woman to marry someone this
is what a man it's not only women so
they don't be like they're only women
get forced no give me just small
examples the man before we go to break
we want to hit this point now sometimes
I say the Muslim and they see their
Muslim man up front the woman's 20 feet
behind him and they say what is this
have we got a simply explain it in
Muslim countries not all of them but in
some cultures the man walks ahead
because there are other men walking when
they come they greet each other right
and so the wife stays behind because
it's nothing to do with her whether this
man is meeting that man right so he just
stands in front from the point of view
and this is what anyway this is one of
my wife explained to me yeah right you
know but if you you but you don't find
that for example in the time of the
Prophet the prophets all awesome would
walk with his wives even sometimes it's
reported they would hold each other's
hands
you know these type of things so you
might be amazed when you go back to
reading the actual life of the Prophet
and what happened in that time that some
things that Muslims in certain cultural
contexts you know they don't practice
those things I give you another example
you know for example in in Pakistani
culture some Pakistani culture you know
the idea of a man and woman seeing each
other naked is even a husband and wife
even a husband and wife in something
they'll even see each other naked it's
like but the Prophet Muhammad and Aisha
used to take showers together they used
to take you know they used to wash
together Yeah right
and they even used to fight with each
other to take the water
another perfect example of culture and
it's man so separate this yeah come to
the so but that's fine if that's your
culture you don't I'm not going to say
you know you can't have that type of
behavior but don't tell everyone that
this is Islam and don't make everyone
think that this is the right way to
behave because your culture is not the
criterion the behavior of the Prophet
Muhammad and his companions that is the
criterion not your culture let's take a
break we'll be right back with more on
addition iserlohn deals otherwise solo
yeah na seuk lesson I would go to my
room lock the door go straight and class
Sangha you know me better than myself
show me the right way and I will not
look to how we leave everything behind a
lot of that crater and it creates
everything it gives intelligence to
people a survivor super PAC Muhammad is
one of the last innocent
god
[Applause]
back here Nadine show giving you some
examples of culture and Islam now there
are just one more one more female
mutilation female genital mutilation is
a ancient practice from the times of
Pharaohs and actually it's something
forbidden by the Prophet moment they did
use the practice circumcision of both
men and women in the time of the Prophet
but it was for the women a very small a
very just a small cut in the Qataris
right that's all that was allowed the
Prophet did not allow you know what is
known as mutilation female genital
mutilation right and that is something
that Prophet himself warned against now
some Muslim countries practice that but
this is something an example of a
culture that actually really goes
against the teachings of Islam so
there's another example of things that
often Muslims some Muslims think that
this is the religion it's not the
religion it's got nothing to do with the
rule and so how can we give us the
formula that now there are some things
that are acceptable with culture we
talked about some okay some foods that I
mentioned and other things that are good
but there are some things now that
conflict with acts of worship the simple
formula is to know what the Quran says
to know what the Prophet Muhammad said
and to know what his companions were
upon once you understand that once you
have that knowledge then you'll begin to
fit into the framework and to see what
is really culture and really what is
really the religion and what are the
bounds and the boundaries between the
two so it does mean that you need to
excuse me you need to know you need to
understand you need to study the source
texts of the religionists the Quran for
some according to the understanding of
the earth do we need a vases do we ask
questions say what's to prove the
evidence exactly because this is what's
important right you it is families not
based upon oh such and such sense so I
saw someone doing this oh I saw some
Muslims doing that I saw some I suppose
so Muslims doing whatever you can find
Muslims drinking it's very clear from
the Quran
the drinking is Haram right you find
Muslims committing acts of terrorism but
you find it very clear from the
teachings of Prophet Muhammad that
terrorism is something that is not
allowed in the religion of Islam so what
Muslims do is not a proof proof is what
God says on what the Prophet says so
what the verbatim word of God says the
Quran what the last and final - of the
mankind of Prophet peace be upon him and
the Companions the best of generations
yep how they understood it that's right
now that is the criteria and with that
said we're coming to an end last closing
and common sense is Justin's and where
people can also get a hold of you if
they need to you can find out more about
our organization www you K and you can
contact me through that website there
thank you very much again for being with
us thanks Eddie it's a pleasure song and
that's an episode of the detail thank
you for tuning in every week we are here
same time same channel we also have the
new detail radio show you can go to the
D show comm blog section you can also
pick up volume 1 volume 2 volume 3 of
the DVD that's of most of our show that
we encourage you to get get them in MSAs
get them in the messages and share this
message of peace peace acquired by
submission to the will of the one god
share this message with the world get
the dvds and tune in every week to the
deen show until next time peace be unto
you
[Music]
I am NOT a standalone if I am not afraid
to stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone I am Not Afraid
[Music]